Bitte schön.
Ausscheinend guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Maharamov ist mein Name.
Ich bin der zuständige Arzt.
Und wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Möckel, Herr Doktor, ich habe Ihren Namen nicht ganz verstanden.
Können Sie ihn bitte wiederholen?
Das ist, wie Maharamov, M-A-H-A-R-A-M-O-Frau.
Maharamov, alles klar.
Herr Doktor, Maharamov, vielen Dank.
Ja, mein Name ist Bernhard Möckel.
Möckel.
Ja.
Mit CK, ne?
Mit CK, richtig, ja.
Herr Möckel, und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 41 Jahre alt, weil dies Jahr 42 Jahre alt ist.
41?
Ja.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ungefähr 1,80 Meter.
Okay, und wie viel wiegend Sie?
Ungefähr 90 Kilogramm.
90?
Ja, ich bin sehr groß.
Herr Möckel, was führt Sie zu uns?
Herr Doktor, ich fange vielleicht mal so an.
Ich habe so vor etwa vier Tagen Halsschmerzen bekommen,
konnte nichts mehr schlucken.
Meine Stimme ist auch dann auch heißer geworden,
also ich konnte nicht mehr gut reden.
Und habe dann jetzt Fieber und Schüttelfrost gehabt
und jetzt auch Entzündung in der Mundschleimhaut.
Das ist, also ich kann nichts mehr essen.
Und dann war ich gestern beim Arzt, der hat Blut abgenommen
und dann hat er mich heute angerufen,
ich sollte sofort ins Krankenhaus gehen,
deswegen bin ich jetzt bei Ihnen.
Okay.
Heute geht es mir auch wirklich nicht gut.
Also ich kann kaum aufdehnen.
Mein Blutdruck ist sehr niedrig, 90 zu 40 habe ich gemessen.
Und mein Puls ist auch sehr schnell.
90 zu 40?
Ja, und mein Puls ist 123 gewesen
und ich bin jetzt zu Ihnen ins Krankenhaus gekommen
und habe immer noch Fieber auch.
Okay.
Warum waren Sie beim Hausarzt?
Gestern war ich dann dort, ja, nachdem ich dann...
Er hat Blut abgenommen und dann?
Genau, und dann hat er gesagt, er meldet sich normal
und hat heute die Laborwerte bekommen, hat mich angerufen
und gesagt, ich muss ins Krankenhaus gehen.
Okay.
Und hat er etwas anderes gesagt?
Also sonst noch etwas.
Nur ganz kurz gesprochen, er hat gesagt,
er schickt dann die Werte per Fax ins Krankenhaus,
weiß nicht, ob sie schon da sind, aber...
Okay, jetzt geht es mal dann.
Ja.
Okay, seit vier Tagen...
Sie haben gesagt, Halsschmerzen, Fieber, Schüttelbrot
und Schleimhaut, Schlüppschmerzen haben Sie auch, ne?
Hab ich auch, ja.
Ja.
Seit vier Tagen...
Gab es einen Auslöse?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Eigentlich nicht so richtig.
Also ich habe halt...
Bekannte Rückenschmerzen, die jetzt seit Wochen
mich doch plagen, aber mit dem Mund, Hals und Fieber
hatte ich keine Probleme gehabt bisher.
Okay, bis Problem beim Wasserlassen, mit dem Stuhlgang?
Also Wasserlassen ist jetzt weniger geworden.
Also heute habe ich gar keinen Regen gelassen.
An die Tage vorher gab es eigentlich jetzt keine großen Problemen.
Auch mit Stuhlgangen war normal.
Ja, trinken Sie viel genug?
Also seit gestern vielleicht nicht mehr so viel, ich weiß es nicht.
Die haben Sie in den letzten Tagen eine Infektion,
eine Inzündererkrankung, wissen Sie?
Also vorher nicht, wie gesagt.
War Sie im Ausland?
Nein, seit einem halben Jahr war ich nicht im Ausland.
Aber vor halben Jahren?
Da war ich in Italien immer gewesen, ja, vor zwei Wochen.
Okay.
Herzrasen, Herzstolpern, Luftnot.
Also ich fühle mich heute halt schwach, weil das Herz schlägt schnell,
aber kein Stolpern, das ist einfach nur ganz schnell.
Und ich bin einfach schlapp, so dass ich wenn ich bis in den Laufe
auch schon müh, also Atmung auch dann schwierig wird.
Aber seit heute erst, gestern, vorgestern war das noch nicht so gewesen.
Ach ja, die haben Sie in den letzten Zeiten abgenommen?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Und wissen Sie, was für ein Brut hat der Haus aus abgenommen?
Was für ein Parameter hat der bestimmt?
Hat gesagt, Blutbild ist nicht in Ordnung, deswegen.
Ist nicht in Ordnung?
Ja, ich muss jetzt einfach raus, ja.
Aber was auffällig war, hat er nicht gesagt?
Hat er mir nicht gesagt, nein.
Dann nehmen wir auch hier Blut, ne?
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Moment.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Hautverfärben oder sowas bemerkt?
Nein, ist mir nichts aufgefallen, Doktor.
Sind Sie blass geworden?
Kann ich so nicht sagen.
Also haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen?
Also ich habe auch chronische Erkrankungen, also Rückenschmerzen,
deswegen nehme ich auch so ein ganzes Zeit-Schmerz-Medikamente ein.
Was war ein Medikament denn?
Also Novalgien, da nehme ich seit vier, fünf Wochen
viermal 30 Tropfen ein für die Rückenschmerzen.
Die Dosierung, würden Sie noch mal sagen?
Novalgien?
Viermal 30 Tropfen.
Aha.
Volgien, ja.
Seit wann?
Also vier, fünf Wochen bestimmt, so lange habe ich die Schmerzen schon.
Ja.
Und warum haben Sie Rückenschmerzen?
Also das habe ich immer wieder mal, also es kommt immer wieder mal vor,
so alle paar Monate, dass ich Rückenschmerzen habe,
weil sich war auch beim Orthopäden, da meinte es am ehesten.
Also degenerativ, hat er gesagt.
Aha.
Ja, Sie sind aber relativ jung, ne? 41 Jahre.
Ja, ich bin Krankenpfleger deswegen.
Ja, das.
Ich bin jetzt, wie wir heben und lagern.
Noch was, außer Rückenschmerz?
Also ich habe Gallensteine, das habe ich jetzt gerade beschwerten aktuell.
Und ich habe mal einen Magengeschwör gehabt,
aber das ist auch schon ungefähr zehn Jahre her.
Aber ich habe ab und zu immer Reflex beschwerten.
Moment.
Nehmen dann auch Pantopazoleil bei Bedarf.
Magengeschwör haben Sie gesagt, Gallenstein haben Sie gesagt, noch was?
Und Asthma habe ich, aber das ist jetzt eher weniger ein Problem.
Wenn es ins Stark ist, nehme ich halt so Salbitamol.
Ja, waren Sie deswegen im Krankenhaus?
Nein.
Salbitamol, ne?
Ja, Salbitamol.
Okay, sind Sie schon mal opferiert worden?
Nein.
Mhm.
Herr Möcke, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr selten, also nur, wenn bestimmte Anlässe sind.
Also vielleicht.
Verzeihbar.
Vielleicht zwei, drei Mal im Jahr, sonst nicht.
Ah ja.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, nehmen wir keine Drogen.
Okay, ist Ihnen allerginen bekannt?
Bisher sind keine Allergien bei mir bekannt, nein.
Die Unverträglichkeit gegen Medikamenten, gegen, wissen Sie nicht, ne?
Bisher ist da nicht, als es wirklich nichts gewesen ist, ich habe nichts gehabt an Problemen.
Okay.
Mhm.
Der Novalgin seit vier, fünf Wochen haben Sie die Pantopazoleil gesagt, ne?
Ja.
Und Saibutamol.
Genau.
Und seitdem haben Sie den Geilensteingang.
Geilensteine.
Geilensteine, genau.
Auch schon.
Fünf, sechs Jahre.
Mhm.
Hat ich mal Beschwerden gehabt, um Oberbauch, das ist damit Ultraschall festgestellt worden,
aber das hat man sonst nicht weiter verfolgt.
Ach ja.
Mhm.
Und haben Sie irgendwie Beschwerden?
Momentan nicht, nein.
Momentan nicht.
Die Halsschmerzen strahlen die Halsschmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Also nur beim Schlucken halt, wenn ich schlucke, dann habe ich da auch noch Schmerzen.
Mhm.
Also, was ist denn von Beruf?
Krankenpfleger, ja.
Kranken?
Ja, ja, ja.
Wo arbeiten Sie denn?
Im Kragenhaus.
Im welchen Kragenhaus, mein ich?
Im Krankenhaus der eiligen Maria.
Hey, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe drei Kinder, ja.
Sind die gesund?
Die sind gesund, ja.
Mhm.
Sie leben zusammen?
Ja.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter ist verstorben, mein Vater lebt noch, ja.
Woran?
Sie ist verstorben?
Meine Mutter ist am ersten Mal ein Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Herzinfarkt.
Mhm.
Und ist der Vater gesund?
Da hat auch ein paar Krankheiten, da hat Rheuma, Herzrhythmusstörungen.
Ansonsten, ja, ist er relativ gesund noch dafür.
Was freien Herzrhythmusstörungen wissen Sie?
Ja, das hat Herzschritt mal bekommen.
Ja.
Was für Rheuma?
Das war früher mal, schweres Rheuma, wobei es nicht ganz klar war, ob das auch rheumatisches Fieber war.
Also das war nicht ganz klar.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe Geschwister, ja.
Zwei Geschwister, ja.
Bruder?
Bruder und Schwester, ja, genau.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, wir haben auch so ein paar Krankheiten.
Also die Schwester hat Diabetes,
und der Bruder hat auch so chronische Damerkrankung.
Okay, dann müssen wir auch den Blutbild bestimmen.
Müssen wir Haus finden, was nicht stimmt.
Können Sie noch etwas geben?
Das Neuvalginen habe ich nicht gegen die Aften, die ich im Mund habe.
Ich habe diese Entzündung gemunt mit Aften, ganz schweren Aften.
Weiß nicht, was Sie mit der Verschreibung können.
Ja, jetzt gebe ich etwas in.
Aber sonst brauchen Sie noch etwas.
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Im Mund habe ich starke Schmerzen, ja.
Da hilft noch ein wenig, nicht genug.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Jetzt gebe ich anders.
Das ist eigentlich nicht ein Schmerzmittel,
sondern ein Lokal-Anesthetikum.
Wie bitte?
Ein Lokal-Anesthetikum.
Ja, das kann ich auch geben.
Wollen Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich kenne mich ein bisschen aus in der Materie.
Ich erzähle manchmal viel.
Nein, das ist gut.
Blutdruck haben Sie auch.
Bitte?
Das ist seit heute Morgen gemessen.
90 zu 40 war 90.
Mein Herzfrequenz war 123.
Haben Sie auch Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe immer noch Fieber.
Er hat auch Schüttelfrost.
Hatte ich jetzt gestern heute kein Schüttelfrost?
Ja, ich habe immer noch Fieber.
Blutdruck haben Sie aber nicht.
Ich fühle mich halt schlapp seit heute.
Deswegen habe ich auch jetzt bei Bewegung ein bisschen Atembeschwerten.
Okay, dann sage ich dir erstmal,
schauen wir uns an den Blut.
Dann spänen wir noch mal.
Alles klar.
Ich habe es jetzt ganz klar verstanden.
Es gibt Fragen aus dem Chat.
Ich gucke gerade mal nach.
Lymphknoten.
Ist ihm nicht aufgefallen jetzt aktuell?
Nachtschweiß hat er nicht.
Husten hat er auch nicht.
Impfstatus, also die normalen Impfungen.
Gripper hat er gemacht, Corona.
Ansonsten hat er die anderen Impfungen auch normal absolviert.
Ja, Lymphknoten war wichtig.
Mundgeruch, ja kann er nicht beurteilen,
aber schon so ein bisschen fauliger Mundgeruch kann sein.
Aber er kann es selbst nicht beurteilen.
Im Genitalbereich hat er keine Wunden.
Nein.
Und da begon er Infektionen nicht bekannt.
Ist ihm jetzt nicht aufgefallen letzten 1, 2 Wochen.
Hat er keinen wissentlichen Kontakt gehabt.
Meine Frage wäre, gibt es jemand,
bei ihrer Umgebung mit ähnlicher Beschwerden?
Keine.
Keine hat Leute beschweren, wie ich.
Ansonsten weißen Flecken im Mund bemerkt.
Also nur die Aften.
Und als die ganzen Gaumen geschwollt und gerötet entzündet.
Ohne Aften.
Gut, weitere Fragen, wenn nicht, dann will ich schon.
Schluftstuhl haben Sie auch, ne?
Schluftstuhl sind ja Schmerzen beim Schlucken, ja.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Also mein Verdachtdiagnose ist
agranocytos, beim Anwauen bei Einnahmen in einer Valgin.
Und sonst war Verdachtdiagnose in Hochschul-Kinglionform.
Aber die Wimpfknoten hat der Patient nicht, aber auf jeden Fall.
Können wir gucken.
OK.
Sonst wegen der dysphagie.
Ja, es habe ich auch so, so vergisst, so war gedacht.
Ja.
Darin oft.
Also Mononikulose kann auch mal so besprechen.
Ah, effektius Mononikulose, ja genau.
Genau.
So die wichtigsten Differenzialdiagnosen, oder halt kann ja auch was sein,
dass es, sag ich mal, eine Angina von Solaris und Ausbreitung in Richtung
Farrings, Larings und Wunschlammort kann eine Reinfektion sein.
Ja, das wäre auch eine normale Differenzialdiosynt.
Aber wegen des Blutbilds,
ja, stimmt.
Das habe ich nicht verraten muss.
Ja.
Also der Haushaltsatz gemessen, in der Tat, war das, die Granulazitten waren null.
Ja, ich bestimmt, ja.
Aber habe ich nicht verraten, aber sind gut selbst darauf gekommen.
Sehr gut.
OK, dann wollen wir Vorstellung machen beim Oberhass oder?
Wenn es mir ein Minuten gibt.
Ja, klar.
Schreiben Sie alles zusammen, dann sind Sie vorstellend.
Ja, OK, wir können anfangen.
OK, das wäre schön.
All schon guten Tag, Herr Atmada.
Die hat 9 Patienten aufgenommen, Herr Möckel, 41-jährige Patienten.
Hat seit vier Tagen Halsschmerzen, Fiebe, hat Schüttelfroß gehabt,
bis Fagi und er hat Stomatitis gesagt,
8. in Mund und war die Blutdruck, hat er 90 zu 40.
Deswegen war er beim Haus aus und Haus aus hat Blut abgenommen.
Und aufgrund des Blutbilds, hat er uns
eingewiesen, die in der Vorgeschichte hatte eine Ruckelschmerzen,
deswegen nimmt er seit vier bis fünf Wochen viermal Portal Novalgin,
30 Tropfen, hat Colostolythiasis und Ulkosventrolcolistisch
schon vorbekannt gegen Panthopazol und Asthma.
Und dagegen nimmt er Sabotamol ein.
Er ist nicht raucher, keine Alliögie schon bekannt,
er arbeitet als Krankenpflege, er vererratet, hat drei gesunde Kinder,
Mutter ist am Herzinfarkt gestorben, Vater leidet an Römer und
Herzrhythmusstörung.
Herzrhythmus, Herzschrittmach, hab ich schon geschrieben.
Der Bruder, beim Bruder befindet sich
Konchendamekanken beim Schwestes Iabit und Brutrofluss schon vorbekannt.
Mein Verdachteragnose ist Aghanacytos, aufgrund der Einnahme von Novalgin,
er hat keinen Lymphknoten, er hat nicht über den Lymphknoten geklagt,
deswegen...
Lymphknoten und Schwellung geklagt.
Lymphknoten und Schwellung, genau.
Aber mein Verdachteragnose ist Horschenglymphoma
und den Oberatomwegsinfekt kann es auch sein.
Erst mal nehme ich Brut auf.
Wie schätzen Sie ihn ein, Klinisch ist der kritisch-unkrittig der Patient?
Wie war denn die Vitalparameter?
Die Vitalblutdruck lag bei 90 zu 40.
Die Pulsbetrag 130.
Das ist aber nicht normal.
Was kann sein?
Was sollen wir machen?
Den Frisken zuvor erst mal nicht geben.
Das wäre ganz gut.
Und schnellstmöglich abgehen.
Pausium wie Novalgin,
gehen wir an den Schmerzmittel,
gehen wir zurück mit den Schmerzen.
Was zum Beispiel?
Erst mal können wir Paracetamol IV geben.
Okay, ja, mein Verstand.
Gut.
Das ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber mich stört ein bisschen
den Blutdruck und seine Herzfrequenz.
Was kann da vorliegen bei den Patienten?
Wenn er Fieber hat und sich schlecht fühlt.
Das kann ja selbst sein.
Auch Antibiotcheterapie können wir anfangen.
Das würde ich auf jeden Fall machen.
Uns vielleicht sogar auf Überwachungsstationen.
Ja, genau.
Kann er selbst sein.
Die Blutwerte CHP von 300.
PCT 15.
Kreatinin 2,5.
Was machen Sie mit ihm?
Wir machen den Ultraschall.
Warum machen Sie Ultraschall?
Erklagte über Oligorie.
Dann müssen wir den Aufstau ausschließen.
Richtig, gut.
Wenn es keinen Aufstau gibt, dann GmbF.
Und Antibiotcheterapie mit Piperz.
Was machen Sie noch?
Er hat ja hohes Fieber auf Schüttelfrost.
Ist das nur wegen der Entzündung im Hals?
Oder kann es aber auch andere Probleme geben?
Rundkantorys machen wir auch.
Das kann auch eine Flamulie sein.
Und Urin.
Also muss Infektfokus so machen.
Auf jeden Fall ja.
Okay, ja.
Was machen Sie für die Acrylonacetosis?
Erstmal haben Sie gesagt, stoppen Sie Neuvalgien.
Neuvalgien, Pause.
Darf man nie wieder nehmen?
Darf man nie wieder nehmen.
Was machen Sie noch?
Normalerweise weiß ich nicht genau.
Oft ist es so, dass das spontan wieder sich bessert.
Den Tagen, ja.
Er hat jetzt ein Sepsis bei einer komplett Acrylonacetosis.
Er hat keine Acrylonacetose mehr.
Was kann man da probieren?
Dann gucken Sie mal.
Ja, Acrylonacetosis, Stimulantfaktor.
Das wäre richtig.
Das wäre die wichtigsten Sachen.
Eine Differenzialdiagnose kam später noch, die auch sehr wichtig ist.
Vor allen Dingen, wenn Sie das Blutbild sehen, dass die Kandocytin 0 sind,
kann das auch anders sein.
Wie gesagt, die Neuhorchklinik kann sein.
Ja, und die Formen, die dann auch das Blutbild verändert.
Also eine Leukämie.
Das ist eine wichtige Differenzialdiagnose.
Was wäre bei Leukämie vielleicht noch auffällig, außer die Kandocytin?
Ein Limknotengeschwindel.
Muss nicht sein.
Ja, Gewichtsveränderung.
Ich meine das Labor.
Ja, etwas noch.
Also auch die anderen Blutreien könnten betroffen sein.
Also Erdrocytin und Rhomocytin.
Das wäre dann vielleicht ein Hinweis auf eine Leukämie.
Als Beagranacetose.
Aber das kann es auch mal als Begleitreaktion geben.
Im Sinne einer Knorermax-Aplasie.
Okay, aber das hat alles Hand und Fuß,
das ist das Hand und Fuß, was Sie gesagt haben.
Nur eine gute Vorstellung.
Danke, Sarah.
Gibt es Kommentare?
Ich gucke mal in den Chat, was noch geschrieben worden ist.
Ich möchte etwas sagen.
Bitte schön.
Am Anfang hat der Arzt übermacht,
dass der Patient eine Shop Hauer.
Er sollte diese Gespräche nicht führen.
Eine kleine Pause.
Und eine Klüssigkeit zuvor.
Oder eine übersehende mit kommentär Feierbrechen.
Danach diese Gespräche weiterführen.
Ja, wäre auf der sicheren Seite, das war nicht ganz eindeutig.
Aber wäre auf der besseren Seite, man so machen würde.
Das ist ein Trüffung sehr wichtiger.
Sie können nicht mit 39-Fieber
diese Gespräche weiterführen.
Oder 90er, 40 über Blutdruck.
Das ist große Fehler.
Das war aber beim Hausarzt.
Das war am Morgen.
Am Morgen.
Das Krankenhauskrank war es so.
Aber die Schilderung war auch nicht so eindeutig.
Es kommt immer auf den Prüfer an.
Wenn man das von ihnen will, dass der Patient einen Schock hat,
dann ist es richtig, was sie sagen.
Da muss man pausieren, die Klüssigkeit zuvor,
die Vitalparameter, und dann erst weiter machen.
Wenn der Prüfer das nicht so möchte, wie ich zum Beispiel,
wenn ich Prüfer wäre, hat er jetzt keinen massiven Schockindex gehabt.
Ich meine, wenn ein Patient ist, der sowieso
eine normale Blutdruck von 100 zu 60 hat,
und dann 90 zu 40 ist es auch nicht so große Unterschiede,
deswegen muss das nicht um, das ist kein grober Fehler.
Aber wenn der Prüfer das im Kopf hat,
dass das Schock ist, dann ist es richtig,
da müssen sie so machen, wie vorgeschlagen.
Also, da sind sie auf der sicheren Seite,
wenn sie da erst mal stoppen, mit der Messen,
Flüssigkeit zuvor, und dann fragen, ob wir dann weiter machen können
nach Fiebersenken.
Das Fieber hatte auch schon seit vier Tagen,
dass es nicht so, dass es akkut ist.
Aber kommt auf den Prüfer an.
Wenn der Prüfer das so haben möchte, dann kann es sein,
dass er sagt, okay, das ist falsch.
Hat aber mit Sprache nichts zu tun, das ist fachlich.
Und bei der Fachspracherprüfung ist zunehmend auch fachlich.
Ein Problem habe ich gehört, nicht nur die Sprache.
Was gibt es im Chat noch?
Schau mal nach.
IV-Hytrationen, also Blutkulturen, ja, klar.
Wenn Sie ein Selbsteshaben, Infektfokus suchen,
haben Sie gesagt, Blutkulturen sind auch immer wichtig.
Und kann noch Zyptinfaktor, Tromostomie,
kann auch noch mal untersuchen, eventuell endeskopisch.
Genau, bei Feprinotopasol, also man muss dann sofort reagieren,
wenn Patient agranos dosat, Nordropinie,
muss man sofort mit Antibiotika anfangen, ist richtig.
Da zählt jede Stunde.
Ein Tag zu spät kann manchmal das Leben von Patienten bedeuten,
bei Nordropinis, richtig.
Okay, ansonsten war ich aber sehr zufrieden.
Hat mir auch schon könnten Sie Diagnostik wiederholen?
Diagnostische Maßnahmen.
Diagnostische Maßnahmen hat er schon sehr gut gesagt.
Also erstmal Laborkontrollen, Blutbild,
mit Ausstrich, wenn es geht, ja.
Dann so allgemeine Parameter wie Kreatinien,
Handstoff, Entzündungsparameter, das wären so die wichtigsten Werte
bei der Labordiagnostik.
Dann haben wir gesagt Infektfokus, wo er Hoßfieber hat
und Hoß-CAP in dem Fall.
Haben wir gesagt, Röntgen, Torax, Urin als Hauptursache
für Infektionen.
Dann hat der Doktor richtigerweise gesagt, der Patient ist anurig,
hat hohes Kreia, da muss er eine Haarnstau ausschließen.
Deswegen hat ein Ultraschall von den Nieren gemacht,
finde ich auch sehr gut.
Und dann haben wir gesagt, an diagnostischen Maßnahmen eventuell,
das hat jemand erwähnt, eine Endoskopie bei Ösofagitis,
aber das muss man nicht unbedingt machen.
Und dann war es das schon aus meiner Sicht, was Diagnostik wichtig ist
bei den Patienten.
Dann die Therapie haben wir gesagt, Antibiotika sofort,
Physikatzufuhr, eventuell Selbstbehandlung,
Affinitivstation mit Katicholaminie, nachdem was notwendig ist
und Wachstumsfaktor bei einer fibränen Neutropinie,
muss man sagen.
Wogegenis Domatitis hilft eigentlich wenig, da müssen die
Blutzellen besser werden.
Man kann aber lokal Anästhetik ergeben, wenn der Patient
dadurch sehr gestört ist.
Ein Pilzmittel kann man geben, wenn man kann die dann nachweisen
kann, ansonsten symptomatisch.
Okay, noch weitere Kommentare.
Sehe ich jetzt nicht, dann werden wir für heute durch,
würde ich sagen.
Das war sprachlich gesehen sehr gut.
Innerhalb haben Sie auch das Wichtigste genannt, das Einzige,
das der Kollege gesagt hat, wenn ein Patient kritisch sein könnte,
müssen Sie überlegen, ob es dann stoppen und dann sagen,
Stabilisierung dann fortführen ist ein Gespräch.
Das wäre eine Sache, die ich auch bei anderen Sachen im
Minterkopf habe, wenn ein Patient mit Luftnot kommt oder so
aus, mit Lungenbolies, kann man auch manchmal dann auch das
Gespräch nicht weiter für einen Diagnostik machen und
dann, oder Herzinfarkt, S.E.K.G. schreiben und dann
weitermachen zum Beispiel.
Aber kommt immer auf den Fall an und auf den Prüfer,
was der Prüfer möchte von Ihnen auch.
Okay.